president zielinski went to Buckingham
Palace to visit King Charles the
Ukrainian president greeted by demonic
as you can see they're the men spending
around 30 minutes together
let's speak to our Royal cross product
Laura bundock who is at Buckingham
Palace for us this afternoon
um and Laura the camera's in there for
the initial greeting and we got a sense
of the pleasantries that were exchanged
before they had that private audience
yeah we do actually as the two were
shaking hands they were they were
chatting with each other we know as
zelenski president zlinski had told
Parliament earlier today this was a
truly special moment for him personally
we understand that he said it was a
great honor to be here thank you for
finding the time for me he told the king
the king said we've all been worried
about you and thinking about your
country for so long I can't tell you the
president replied to him thank you so
much the king then went on to say that
he'd heard that the president had
addressed both houses earlier and Sir Mr
zielinski then said to him that it had
been a big support that they had been a
big support to him the king replying I'm
so glad then the meeting we understand
carried on in private for around 30
minutes it took place here at Buckingham
Palace inside the 1844 room a room the
royal family reserves for the most
important the most distinguished of
guests they were served tea present also
in the meeting not just king and the
president but the king's private
secretary the president's head of office
and the head of Foreign Affairs
Ukrainian head of Foreign Affairs as
well the meeting lasting as I say around
half an hour a warm meeting by all
accounts though judging from those
initial comments they talked in private
about the continuing conflict in Ukraine
and the role that Britain had paid so
far in supporting that we know there has
been this strong bond this strong sense
of support from the royal family
although they don't get involved in the
politics there's a lot they can do to
show support in situations like this the
king of Prince of Wales spoken out very
strongly in support of Ukraine before
and the queen you might even remember
back in March last year very subtly but
significantly had that huge bowl of
flowers at Windsor Castle when she
greeted the Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau those flowers in the
Ukrainian flag colors of blue and yellow
so a significant day today for both men
it's the first time the king and
president zelenski have met this meeting
taking uh taking up half an hour of each
other's time very much talking about as
I say the ongoing conflict and the role
that Britain has played and no doubt
you'd think the president would be
interested in talking to the king more
about the military support
um the Britain is offering given the
king's role as as head of the Armed
Forces but um the president left a short
while ago crowds had gathered here
actually outside Buckingham Palace many
of them waving flags as the president
left